20,3 milliarden euro fließen in diesen
wichtigen bereich bildung und forschung
und es wird sicherlich noch mehr werden
müssen das ist allen beteiligten klar
bettina stark watzinger hat sich schon
für werbungs klassen nach dem vorbild
von 20.15 ausgesprochen für die vielen
kinder und jugendlichen die in diesen
tagen nach deutschland kommen werden und
da wird sicherlich über den etat entwurf
noch mehr geld notwendig werden aber
lauten wir was die ministerin uns zu
sagen hat allerdings haben wir auch die
informationen dass die beiden sich
gleich in brüssel äußern wird ich hoffe
dass beide redner hier bei uns zu sehen
sein werden liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen während der haushaltsberatungen
führen tobt in der ukraine ein brutaler
an aktions krieg auf die ukraine von
russischer seite wir alle sind gefordert
das leid der menschen zu lindern und
russland zu isolieren wir tun das indem
ihr die wissenschaftliche kooperation
mit staatlichen stellen eingestellt
haben in dem wir zusammen mit den
ländern der wissenschaft und den
stiftungen flüchtenden
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern und studierenden bei
uns chancen geben wird in
denen wir
mit franca unterstützen und in
zusammenarbeit mit dem
bildungsministerium der ukraine den
kindern und jugendlichen wieder ein
stück normalität und bildung geben sei
es im ukrainischen digitalen
bildungssystem oder in unseren schulen
der angriff auf die ukraine sie hat
unsere regierungsarbeit verändert aber
eines ist unverändert geblieben
die bedeutung von bildung und forschung
theodor heuss wird zitiert mit die
äußere freiheit der vielen lebt von der
inneren freiheit des einzelnen ob
das informations- oder das wissen der
demokratie richtig ist dass jeder euro
für bildung eine doppelte investition
ist in jeden einzelnen
und für uns alle meine damen und herren
die rohstoffabhängigkeit
von russland hat gezeigt wir müssen
endlich mehr für unsere technologische
souveränität ihr tun nicht weil wir uns
abschotten wollen nicht weil wir wissen
dass der freihandel wichtig ist sondern
weil wir anhand unserer werte
entscheiden wollen mit wem ihr handel
betreiben meine damen und herren dieses
bus gehört wenig wurde getan jetzt
machen wir tempo für die freiheit
das spiegelt auch unser haushaltsentwurf
wieder 20,3 milliarden euro investieren
die in bildung und forschung das sind
über zwei milliarden euro mehr als 2009
dem letzten haushalt für corona entgegen
dem vorhaben der großen koalition steigt
der haushalt mittelfristig eher sinkt
nicht und wir haben bereits in dem
laufenden haushalt die wichtigsten
ersten wichtigen projekte angeschoben
obwohl wir auch das gehört zur wahrheit
große haushaltsrisiken übernommen haben
ein kleines beispiel der pva nicht bis
zum schluss gegen finanziert und
trotzdem
zukunftsinvestitionen behalten priorität
für neue chancen wir sind das chancen
ministerium wir machen tempo bei der
regel damit hält rauskommen aus dem
mittelmaß bei der jüngsten kmk haben wir
in großer einigkeit die lübecker
erklärung abgegeben weil uns wichtig war
dass wir geflüchteten aus der ukraine
perspektiven eröffnen hier hat der
schulterschluss zwischen bund und land
geklappt das geht auch an anderen
wichtigen stellen denn eines eint uns
bildung schafft lebenschancen und
deswegen darf der bildungserfolg nicht
länger von der sozialen herkunft
abhängen was haben wir vorher gesehen
die digital packt nimmt fahrt auf aber
noch zu langsam das zeigen die aktuellen
zahlen wir müssen weiter beschleunigen
mit der exzellenzinitiative berufliche
bildung verleihen wir der beruflichen
ausbildung neuen schub und ganz wichtig
das bafög muss schnell attraktiver
moderner und flexibler werden
allein
2022 in 2,3 milliarden euro bereit den
eigenen weg selbstbestimmt gehen können
seine talente entfalten und einbringen
können das ist essenziell für unsere
freiheit wir machen tempo bei forschung
und innovation damit wir unabhängiger
werden von rohstofflieferanten
souveräner bei den technologien auch für
mehr nachhaltigkeit mit china stehen wir
in einer werte konkurrenz
auseinandersetzung freiheit statt
kontrolle vertrauen statt überwachung
und gerade deshalb ist es sinnvoll jetzt
in zukunftsfelder zu investieren in
quantentechnologie in it-sicherheit in
mikroelektronik in künstliche
intelligenz wir müssen schneller werden
von unserer hervorragenden
grundlagenforschung zu hervorragenden
neuen produkten zu kommen und deswegen
schaffen wir die deutsche agentur für
transfer und innovation in diesem jahr
mit einem start von 15 millionen euro
seien sie versichert das wird mir meine
damen und herren die springt nicht
schneller und agiler werden die
bundesagentur für sprung innovation
werden wir den titel ansatz im
haushaltsjahr
2022 fast verdoppeln und dann weiter
erhöhen sie erhält ein freiheits gesetz
denn für uns ist klar das
innovationsland deutschland darf nicht
stillstehen wenn es um die zukunft gehen
bis
2026 planen wir mit vier milliarden euro
mehr als die vorgängerregierung damit
investieren wir in forschung und
entwicklungen steigern das ganze auf 3,5
prozent des bruttoinlandsproduktes bis
vom britischen philosophen und
mathematiker alfred north whitehead
stammt der kluge satz ich zitiere die
kunst des fortschritts besteht darin
inmitten des wandels ordnung zu wahren
inmitten der ordnung den wandel aufrecht
zu halten
beides tun wir mit diesem
haushaltsentwurf wir halten kurs und
setzen impulse für neues vielen dank
meine
bettina stark watzinger die neue
bildungs und forschungsministerium die
einzelnen positionen mal durchgegangen
der größte posten in ihrem bereich ist
das bafög
2,33 milliarden euro nach ordentlicher
auf der ganzen letzten
berlin schon jetzt stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende ministerin in ihrer
letzten rede hier im deutschen bundestag
haben sie von missionen gesprochen und
ich dachte das
ist ja visionär das ist zukunft dass es
begeistern bei missionen da denke ich an
den weltraum an den astronauten matthias
maurer aus meiner heimat der gerade auf
der iss ist der gestern einen
außeneinsatz gemacht hat der vor zwei
wochen mit schülerinnen und schülern aus
meinem wahlkreis gesprochen hat und die
wird sich inspiriert hat mit seinen
erkenntnissen von der ss und so eine
mission haben sie auch angekündigt und
ich muss auch sagen die ziele die sie
mit dieser mission verbinden die
begeistern mich auch dass es mehr
bildungsgerechtigkeit mehr mut mehr
innovation mehr fortschritt das haben
sie alles angekündigt aber zu einer
mission hört nicht allein die vision
sondern um eine ich habe meine damen und
herren und sie sehen ist im kleinen
fenster wir müssen da die hier direkt
angegeben nach brüssel us präsident joe
biden äußert sich dort und zum dritten
ein guter zusammenhalt aller akteure die
an dieser mission beteiligt
und ich würde einmal einen blick darauf
werfen was davon sieben bisher
vorbereitet haben in den ersten 100
tagen ihrer amtszeit beginnen wir mit
dem budget wir hatten ja heute über den
haushalt sie haben gesagt dass steigt
total also ich sehe jetzt erstmal für
das nächste jahr sinkt das budget
und dann steigt es im lauf der
legislaturperiode um
1,5 prozent zum vergleich in der letzten
legislaturperiode haben wir den
haushaltsansatz um 20 prozent gesteigert
und im laufe der amtszeit von angela
merkel greift so viel verantwortung
für ihre lieblingsprojekte wie das
startchancen programm das finden wir
noch gar nicht im budget sie können
dankbar sein dass der pakt für forschung
und innovation
abgesichert ist da liege nämlich die
haupt steigerungen das ist wirklich das
versprechen an die wissenschaft an die
forschung an die innovation in unserem
land dass wir ihnen verlässlichkeit
bieten und das ist noch das ergebnis der
vorgängerregierung
und frau ministerin sie haben selbst das
sagt in zeiten des wandels brauchen der
innovation sie haben selbst geschmacks
statt kleiner schüttet des verzichts
wollen sie große schütte des
fortschritts als sie sorgen sie dafür
dass der haushalt jedes haus aus diesem
anspruch auch rechnung trägt
zwei sachen strategie und steuerung auch
hier will ich wieder zitieren nämlich in
diesem fall ihren staatssekretär thomas
sattelberger der im oktober angekündigt
hat die regierung werde mit
intelligenten prognose prozessen
stringenten projektmanagement und
messbaren ziel und leistungsindikatoren
aufwarten wo sind sie
ein solches projekt management bräuchte
es zum beispiel beim thema
digitalisierung und liebe kollegen der
fdp sie haben wie wir gefordert dass es
in dieser legislatur ein
legislaturperiode ein digital
ministerium braucht bis heute wissen wir
bei ganz wir sind digitalen themen nicht
wer den hut aufhat werbung für zuständig
ist herr wissing kann es uns nicht sagen
die bundesregierung kann es nicht sagen
und frau ministerin stadt wazin dafür so
viele ihrer themen brauchen sie
digitalisiert und digitale innovationen
und dann kann es jedoch nicht zufrieden
stellen dass sie nach 100 tagen immer
noch nicht wissen wer in dieser
regierung wofür zuständig ist
und selbst bei ihren eigenen projekten
haben wir bisher keine konzeption die
daten die agentur für transfer wurde an
gewünscht ein konzept haben wir noch
nicht im haushalt steht geld das ist
aber gesperrt wurden von ihrem
parteifreund christ werden nimmt da mit
dem vermerk das geld können wir erst
freigeben wenn ein vernünftiges konzept
vorliegt wo ist es fehlanzeige als die
letzte woche in leipzig waren oder auch
heute noch mal hier haben sie die sprint
gelobt und ein sprint freiheits gesetz
und aussicht gestellt eckpunkte
vorstellte was genau sie damit sagen
wollen können wir nicht federn 2 gibt es
heute liegt nichts auf dem tisch das
bafög änderungsgesetz haben wir auch
noch nicht im bundestag das soll aber
zum wintersemester schon in kraft treten
und auch verbesserung führt beim digital
park wurden für märz angekündigt es ist
jetzt sehr vierundzwanzigster märz auch
hier haben wir noch keine konkreten
vorschläge ich sage ihnen werden sie
bitter konkret damit wir mit den themen
fordern
und was mich am meisten
gekümmert schon nach 100 tagen drücke
der zusammenhalt in dieser regierung sie
haben das wichtige thema flüchtlinge
angesprochen ich würde erwarten dass
sich die familienministerin der
sozialminister und der
gesundheitsminister und die
bundesbildungsminister den man einen
tisch setzen und mit ländern und
kommunen besprechen was es jetzt braucht
und die vielen tausend flüchtlingskinder
gut in unsere schulen zu integrieren
auch hier keine zusammenarbeit keine
konkreten ideen und deshalb kollegen sie
haben leider keine zeit mehr ich komme
zum schluss und wünsche mir dass ihre
missionen erfolgreich sind aber dafür
müssen sie auch die voraussetzung
schaffen und zwar jetzt und
[Applaus]
für die spd fraktion erhält jetzt das
wort dr vips
frau präsidentin frau ministerin wehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen und
herren bildung in wissenschaft sind das
fundament unserer demokratie
das fundament unseres wohlstandes und
das fundament unserer freiheit und weil
uns in diesen tagen auch so
schrecklicher weise vor augen geführt
wird die fragil unsere demokratie unser
wohlstand unsere freiheit sind vorab das
klare bekenntnis sicherheit im wandel
heißt für uns auch dass die geflüchteten
aus der ukraine
ob das kinder sind die aus der schule
gerissen worden sind oder jugendliche
die mitten im studium stecken dass wir
sie dass wir euch darin unterstützen
dass dieser schreckliche krieg euch
nicht auch noch euer recht auf bildung
klaut
wir wissen uns viele hochschulen und
schulen bereits voll in die
unterstützung vor ort eingetreten sind
die universität bielefeld beispielsweise
städtischen turnhalle als notunterkunft
zur verfügung die busschule bei uns in
der sender organisiert die ganz viele
andere einen spendenlauf und die
handwerkskammer ostwestfalen-lippe wie
viele andere auch berieten bereitet oder
bereitet unterstützung vor für die unter
unternehmen die jobchancen für
geflüchtete bereitstellen möchten und
für all diese bemühungen in der ganzen
republik einen ganz herzlichen dank wenn
es geht jetzt darum dass wir den
menschen die zu uns gekommen sind
ermöglichen ihren bildungsweg
fortzusetzen und dass sie arbeit finden
meine damen und herren bildung des
risses fundament unserer demokratie
unseres wohlstandes unserer freiheit
bildung ganz individuell ist auch
fundament für ein selbstbestimmtes leben
und für wirtschaftliche unabhängigkeit
und darum werden wir die mittel für
bildung und forschung
steigern gemeinsam mit den ländern damit
es vor allem dort ankommt wo es
gebraucht wird das beginnt mit der
frühkindlichen bildung geht über die
schulen die wir besonders da fordern
fördern wollen wo die startchancen
weniger gut sind und das führt zu einem
grundlegend reformierten bafög und wenn
ich das bachhaus greifen darf dann
werden wir das strukturell modernisieren
das was in der letzten legislaturperiode
leider nicht gelungen ist aber wir
werden es strukturell modernisieren weil
doch völlig überholt ist das in zeiten
von lebenslangen lernen die altersgrenze
besteht weil wir endlich eine förderung
für ein teilzeitstudium brauchen weil
wir digitaler und elternunabhängige
herzen her kommen wollen und frau
ministerin sie haben uns an ihrer seite
wenn es darum geht diese großen projekte
so umzusetzen wie wir sie im
koalitionsvertrag vereinbart haben aber
ich sage an dieser stelle auch wir
wollen auch einfordern dass es
insbesondere bei den bund länder
projekten eine bessere parlamentarische
beteiligung gibt aber da die
fdp-fraktion das ja auch in der länge
legt letzten legislaturperiode immer
wieder gefordert haben glaube ich
kriegen wir das gut hin
meine damen und herren bereits es um
dieses papier haben wir das 35 prozent
ziel vereinbart dreieinhalb prozent der
aufwendungen des bruttoinlandsprodukt
sollen für forschung und entwicklung
aufgewandt werden und wir brauchen das
weil eben forschung und entwicklung auf
fundament unserer ökologischen
wirtschaftlichen und gesellschaftlichen
herausforderungen sind und wir werden
den beitrag dafür erhöhen nicht nur
monetär sondern auch die lösung dieser
herausforderung besser adressieren und
beantworten können indem wir die
forschung zielgerichteter missions-
orientiert aufstellen in sechs zentralen
zukunftsfeldern werden wir dem bmbf
themenschwerpunkte damit an die hand
geben das ganze selbstverständlich unter
voller wahrung der freiheit von
forschung und lehre aber ich sage auch
wer milliarden öffentlicher mittel
verwendet er hat auch den anspruch über
das mit zu entscheiden wofür das geld
aufgewendet immer ergebnisoffen aber
ganz klar dahin dass sich in den
haushalt auch abbildet wie die
wissenschaft unterstützen kann wie wir
diese gesellschaftlichen
herausforderungen lösen
meine damen und herren eine der
wichtigsten voraussetzungen für gute
forschung für erfolgreiche forschung ist
das forschende gut arbeiten können
und als jemand der selbst mit vielen
befristeten verträgen als doktorandin
und als postdoc auch gearbeitet und
bevor stadt weiß ich wie viel raum ist
allein einnimmt wenn man unter
unsicheren zukunft bedingungen forschen
soll wie viel raum dass im kopf einnimmt
der fehlt für forschungs hypothesen für
ergebnisse interpretationen aber auch
zeitliche ressourcen die es frisst wenn
man sich um den anschlussvertrag bemühen
muss und darum haben wir die mittel
ansatz zur förderung des
wissenschaftlichen nachwuchs erhöht wir
werden aber auch stärker karrierewege
außerhalb der professur unterstützen und
wir werden hochschulen die sich auf den
weg machen ihre personal finance
organisationsstruktur zu modernisieren
finanziell unterstützen weil ich auch
überzeugt davon will das ist auch die
althergebrachte hierarchische struktur
der deutschen wissenschaft ist die in
vielen stellen im weg steht wenn es um
bessere arbeitsbedingungen geht und so
können wir endlich endlich dann mit
zusammen der novelle des bis zeit vg
dazu kommen dass für verbesserungen von
bundesseite anschließend für bessere
arbeit und ich will bereits an dieser
stelle plädieren an die länder ziehen
sie da bitte mit
ein weiterer punkt bei dem ich endlich
rufen möchte ist die daten wenn die
debatte um die deutsche
transfergemeinschaft führen wir schon
ein paar jahre und jetzt kommt endlich
die deutsche agentur für transfer und
innovation wir wollen bei der transfer
forschung besser wäre ich bin überzeugt
davon dass wir das auch gut hin kann
insbesondere weil wir besonders gut
aufgestellter hochschule für angewandte
wissenschaften haben wer übrigens eine
blaupause dafür wie dieser
verbundforschung zwischen unternehmen
und hochschulen
wissenschaftseinrichtungen gelingen kann
wer eine blaupause dafür sucht den lade
ich herzlich in meiner heimat ein denn
mit witz owl sind wir seit zehn jahren
sehr erfolgreich dabei verbundprojekte
mit lösungen für industrie 4.0 zu
erforschen dazu soll auch zusammenführen
was es an einzelnen förderungen in den
verschiedenen häusern schon gibt und da
wenn ich mich an der stelle manz bmw k
franziska brantner als staatssekretärin
ist da das plädoyer an der stelle
forschung die es als förderung beim bmw
k gibt da für die daten auch zu nutzen
af und 10 werden die beispiele lassen
sie uns das unter der die bündeln denn
nur so schaffen wir es dass es
sichtbarer wird in dem nur so schaffen
wir es dass wir dann auch wegkommen von
dem voerder wer war dass das eine haus
zu wenig weiß was das andere macht
meine damen und herren wir haben uns im
koalitionsvertrag viel vorgenommen wir
wollen mehr fortschritt wagen auch im
bereich bildung und forschung darum ist
es richtig dass der plattform des bmbf
ab 22 von 20,3 milliarden auf 21,1
milliarden auf 6 bis 25 das sind 4
milliarden mehr als bisher vorgesehen
haben und auch darum freue ich mich auf
die beratungsrunden und danke für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
vielen dank
und es folgt der abgeordnete markus buhl
für die afg fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren der regierungsentwurf für den
haushalt des bundesministeriums für
forschung und bildung soll für 2022 bei
knapp über 20 milliarden euro liegen
wenn man sich den einzelplan betrachtet
frau ministerin dann bleibt auch dieses
jahr der eindruck eines gebundenen
gemischtwarenladens umso wichtiger ist
da die richtige priorisierung bei der
mittelverteilung
schwerpunktsetzung wie zb einen der so
wichtigen bereiche wie der künstlichen
intelligenz kommen mir dabei deutlich zu
kurz mit der grundgesetzänderung im jahr
2009 10 wurde der föderalismus weiter
aufgeweicht der bund greift mit dem
digital parkschule in die kompetenzen
der länder ein einen durchschlagenden
erfolg kann man allerdings bisher nicht
sehen beim basis park digitale schule in
höhe von fünf milliarden euro sind zum
jahresende
2021 gerade einmal 19 prozent der
fördermittel abgeflossen in meinem
heimatbundesland thüringen wurden von
der rot rot grünen minderheitsregierung
bis zu diesem zeitpunkt überhaupt keine
mittel abgerufen was ziemlich
bezeichnend ist frau ministerin wenn das
tempo weiter so läuft ähnlich wie beim
flächendeckenden breitbandausbau haben
die schüler von heute ihre ausbildung
längst beendet wenn der digital
parkschule vollendet ist
die modernisierung und instandhaltung
von schulgebäuden wurde über jahrzehnte
durch die bundesländer vernachlässigt so
dass eine milliardenhohe
investitionsstau aufgelaufen ist dabei
ist der investitionsstau in der
gebäudeinfrastruktur mittlerweile ein
massives problem
oder anders gesagt was nützt das neueste
tablet wenn die sanitären einrichtungen
nicht funktionieren der putz von den
wänden fällt oder fenster nicht zu
öffnen sind die länder eigentlich ihre
pflicht nachkommen und den kommunen
fehlt kommunen fehlen leider oft die
notwendigen eigenmittel wie als auch die
bundestagsfraktion werden in dieser
haushaltsberatung eigene vorschläge
unterbreiten damit schule in
funktionstüchtigen schulgebäuden
stattfinden kann
aus unserer sicht kommen die vorgelegten
haushaltsentwurf die förderung der
beruflichen bildung zu kopf wir setzen
uns für chancengleichheit ein egal ob
mit mit studienabschluss oder berufliche
ausbildung im vergleich mit unseren
europäischen nachbarländern sehen wir
immer wieder dass deutschland wegen
seiner dualen ausbildung eine geringe
jugendarbeitslosigkeit hat wir können
stolz sein auf unsere handwerker und
industriearbeiter die deutsche qualität
weltweit bekannt gemacht haben sie
gehören gefördert unterstützt ich danke
für ihre aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
und als nächstes folgt für bündnis
90/die grünen bruno bühne
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen liebe frau
ministerin frau spielen die
bundesregierung ist jetzt seit 100 tagen
in ampen amt sie haben 16 jahren regiert
sie haben 16 jahre die
bildungsministerin gestellt wo war denn
ihr digitalen ministerium ich habe es
nicht gesehen ich habe nur ein bisschen
was vom büro per mitbekommen und die
hatte vor einem flug taxis im kopf also
mal ehrlich ein bisschen piano vocal und
gestatten sie mir noch eine zweite
vorbemerkung in den vergangenen tagen
häufen sich berichte über russische
angriffe auf zivile einrichtungen
teilweise auf kindergärten und schulen
in denen menschen zuflucht suchen es
gibt zahlreiche tote und verletzte das
sind angriffe auf wehrlose menschen die
sich an orten in sicherheit bringen wo
bis vor kurzem noch schule unterricht
war es sind aber auch angriffe auf die
infrastruktur die der ukraine und ihrer
bevölkerung schaden zufügen werden
dieser krieg muss enden und ich bin der
bundesregierung und allen voran annalena
baerbock sehr sehr dankbar dass sie
alles dafür tun
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir haben
im koalitionsvertrag deutlich gemacht
dass wir ein jahrzehnt der
zukunftsinvestitionen bäumen der etat
für bildung und forschung steht dabei
selbstverständlich im zentrum der
aufmerksamkeit wenn wir den
wirtschaftsstandort deutschland stärken
wollen brauchen wir investitionen in
alle bildungsbereiche die positiven
effekte der investition geben jedoch
deutlich weiter als über die
wirtschaftlichen vorteile hinaus
investitionen in bildung ermöglichen
individuelle unabhängigkeit und soziale
teilhabe
die entscheidend zu einer offenen und
gerechten gesellschaft beitragen
investitionen in forschung ermöglichen
innovationen die den wohlstand in
deutschland auch in zukunft sichern
können sie liefern erkenntnisse die es
uns ermöglichen die auswirkungen des
klimawandels besser zu verstehen um
angemessen und passgenau zu reagieren
investitionen und bildung und forschung
sind daher zukunftsinvestitionen in den
wohlstand und das wohlergehen unserer
gesellschaft
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
der politik der haushaltsentwurf ist ein
guter entwurf das will ich ausdrücklich
sagen trotz corona trotz des
angriffskrieges auf die ukraine sind im
gesamthaushalt
30,4 milliarden für bildung und
forschung vorgesehen das ist ein rekord
der allein im einzelnen plant 30
enthaltene bildungs und forschungsetat
wird bis 2026 auf
21,1 milliarden anwachsen das bedeutet 4
milliarden mehr als die
vorgängerregierung vorgesehen hat sie
sehen die ampel koalition ist sich ihrer
verantwortung bewusst und investiert
nachhaltig und zukunftsorientiert in
künftige generation
als einen ersten großen reformschritt
sieht der vorliegende entwurf vor die
bafög mittel für studierende um 350
millionen euro anzuheben dieser schritt
trägt maßgeblich zur
chancengerechtigkeit in deutschland bei
er ermöglicht es uns sowohl die zahl an
bafög empfänger innen als auch die
bedarfssätze signifikant zu erhöhen die
union hat eine gerechte reform des bafög
nicht auf die kette bekommen wir machen
unsere jetzt ran weil wir wissen dass
gute und gerechte bildung eben nicht vom
welt für abhängige und wir vergessen
dabei nicht die berufliche bildung wir
fördern die aufstiegsfortbildung mit 786
millionen das sind rund 47 prozent mehr
als im vorjahr wir unterstützen damit
nicht nur studierende sondern die breite
der gesellschaft unsere azubis in zeiten
massiver transformation auf dem
arbeitsmarkt vor dem hintergrund des
fachkräftemangels ist das so wichtig wir
investieren in die zukunft stellen über
eine milliarde für die entwicklung neuer
technologien bereit gesetzen bereits im
ersten haushalt das um was sie von der
union immer angekündigt aber eben nie
gemacht haben und das gleiche gilt für
die innovationsförderung wir verdoppeln
den ansatz für sprung innovation und wir
gründen die agentur für transfer und
innovation die union hat
gründungswillige wissenschaftler in
jahre lang im regen stehen gelassen und
riesiges potenzial verschenkt das ändern
wir jetzt und das ist gut so
die großen
leistungsstarken institute und
außeruniversitären einrichtungen atmen
auf und auch deren finanzierung bauen
wir aus und sorge für planungssicherheit
es macht spaß darüber zu sprechen das
merken sie weil unsere koalition eine
neue ära für den wirtschafts und
wissenschaftsstandort deutschland
einleitet
aber liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich
will nicht nur diesen entwurf abfeiern
ich will auch kritische töne anklingen
lassen
im bereich der
wissenschaftskommunikation hätte ich mir
mehr mut gewünscht der ansatz wird zwar
um 32 prozent gesteigert aber die
ambitionslos sich kite der union in
diesem bereich darf uns eben kein
vergleich kriteriums sein wir alle haben
in den letzten jahren erlebt wie
wahrheiten als lügen und lügen als
wahrheiten verkauft werden um alt
kanzlerin merkel bei einer großen rede
zu zitieren fake news vergiften den
politischen diskurs fakten zum
klimawandel oder zur wirkung von
impfstoffen werden geleugnet zu viele
den rechten narrativen auf den leim wir
müssen besser werden bei der vermittlung
von wissen wir müssen wissenschaft
verstehbar machen und das muss sich auch
im haushalt abbilden wissenschafts
kommunikation und wissenstransfer sind
nicht nice to have sie sind ein
must-have hier muss in den nächsten
jahren mehr passieren
liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der vorliegende
entwurf stößt erste wichtige projekte
der neuen ampel koalition an die nun im
parlamentarischen haushaltsverfahren und
in den kommenden jahren noch weiter
entwickelt werden müssen investitionen
in grundlagenforschung zur
nachhaltigkeit klima und energie sind
essentielle bestandteile des etats um
deutschlands sicherer vor den
auswirkungen der klimakrise zu machen
diese mitte gilt es kurz und
mittelfristig zu erhöhen auch der zweite
teil der bafög-reform die
digitalisierung von bildungsstätten
sowie der gerechte zugang zu bildung
werden uns in den kommenden jahren
beschäftigen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich habe
bis vor kurzem selbst noch studiert und
auch für eine gewisse zeit bafög bezogen
bis sich erfreulicherweise von der
heinrich böll stiftung gefördert wurde
ich weiß wie es ist für zwei bis
dreihundert euro alles offenlegen zu
müssen und behörden abzuklappern und
noch ein dokument einzureichen und noch
ein dokument einzureichen und noch und
dokument einzureichen und ich kann mich
gut erinnern trotz dass ich gearbeitet
habe neben neben dem studium wie der
druck des dispos zum ende des monats
gestiegen ist liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen so sollte es nicht sein das
bafög muss eltern unabhängiger werden es
muss unbürokratischer werden und es muss
garantieren dass sich studios auf ihre
ausbildung konzentrieren können und
nicht auf die e mail korrespondenz mit
dem bafög-amt das ist unser gemeinsames
ziel und das geben wir an liebe kollegen
und verlegen herzlichen dank
vielen dank
und für die linke
folgt die kollegin doktor gesine lötzsch
vielen dank sehr geehrte frau
präsidentin meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren krieg hat viel mit bildung
und forschung zu tun das wusste schon
bundespräsident gustav heinemann von der
spd er sagt am ersten september 1969 in
einer radiosendung wir brauchen eine
friedensforschung meine damen und herren
nicht mit an dieser stelle nochmal ganz
dort ja meine damen und herren und hier
wird der einzelplan 30 bildung und
forschung beraten und gerade hat mit
ihrer rede begonnen gesine lötzsch die
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
für diesen breiten der linksfraktion
sofortigen waffenstillstand und diese
armee muss aus der ukraine abgezogen
werden die menschen in der ukraine und
überall in der welt haben ein recht auf
frieden
wir müssen auch über die zukunft
diskutieren und wir müssen uns die frage
stellen wie wir mit russland nach putin
umgehen wollen und darum ist es wichtig
dass wir die kooperationen mit den
russischen wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern weiter pflegen und
darum ist es wichtig dass wir die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
die in russland bleiben bleiben müssen
aber gegen den krieg sind auch deutlich
unterstützen das ist aufgabe meine damen
und herren
und ich finde es auch richtig dass die
kooperation nicht überall abgebrochen
wird als vorbild können wir die
raumfahrt nehmen auf der iss arbeiten
astronauten kosmonauten aus den usa aus
russland und aus deutschland zusammen
und das sollte unsere hoffnung für die
zukunft geben meine damen und herren das
bildungssystem in deutschland ist
chronisch unterfinanziert
deutschland liegt jenseits von platz 30
im bildungsraum gegen der organisation
für wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung oecd
was öffentliche ausgaben für bildung
betrifft und in keinem anderen land
vergleichbar an land hängt der
bildungserfolg so sehr davon ab wie
reicht die eltern sind das muss sich
ändern meine damen und herren
für das 100 euro sondervermögen
bundeswehr soll die schuldenbremse nicht
mehr gelten da wird der turbo
eingeschaltet aber für bildung und
forschung wird diese zukunftsbranche ab
20 23 wieder anziehen wir brauchen also
eine beseitigung der schuldenbremse aus
unserem grundgesetz diese
grundgesetzänderung des dringlich meine
damen und herren
stellen wir uns einen augenblick vor wir
hätten 100 milliarden euro
sondervermögen bildung und forschung das
kommunal panel 20 21 der kreditanstalt
für wiederaufbau kfw berichtet von einem
investitionsstau bei den kommunen von
149 milliarden euro und davon entfallen
über 50 milliarden auf den bereich
bildung hier müssen wir investieren das
ist auch ein großer friedensdienst
vielen dank
gesine lötzsch die heute schon öfter
gesprochen hat und immer mal wieder die
100 milliarden für die bundeswehr bringt
in der tat allerdings ist der
bildungsetat etwas geschrumpft 20,3
milliarden euro
25 prozent weniger
als im vorjahr aber in den ergänzungs
haushalt der noch fertig wird wird
sicher nicht dieser bereich auch bedacht
werden christoph meyer von fdp 16 jahre
cdu geführte bildungsministerium
davon die letzten davon die letzten vier
jahre geprägt von einer hausspitze die
regelmäßig überfordert war mit den
themen die regelmäßig fremdelte mit den
themen von der milchkanne über das
christliche menschenbild was vor
technologischen fortschritt gestellt
wurde von den peinlichkeiten beim
hochschulpakt was weg entfremdung
vermitteln angeht nicht rückforderung
von überzahlten mitteln bafög ebenfalls
schon erwähnt wurden digital packt und
ich glaube die rede von der neuen
bildungsministerin vor stark watzinger
hat sehr sehr deutlich gezeigt dass
jetztzeit es für einen neustart in der
bildungs und forschungspolitik und dafür
tritt diese koalition an
es ist gut dass wir endlich eine
kompetente ministerin haben für die
begriffe wie algorithmus oder künstliche
intelligenz keine fremdworte sind die
klar macht dass wir ein fokus auf
bildungs- und forschungspolitik in
dieser koalition legen wollen und dieser
fokus der spiegelt sich auch in der
finanzplanung wieder vier milliarden
euro mehr bis 20 26 gesteigert die
öffentlichen bildungsausgaben das wurde
hier bereits mehrfach erwähnt bis 2025
auf 35 prozent des
bruttoinlandsproduktes der haushalt ist
ein haushalt für fortschritt eine
initialzündung für die dekade der
zukunftsinvestition mit diesem haushalt
wird endlich tempo gemacht für
lebenslange beste bildung geschaffen
aufstiegschancen klarer fokus auf junge
menschen eine viertel milliarde euro
mehr bafög stärkung im zweiten
regierungsentwurf zum ersten
regierungsentwurf den sie noch zu
verantworten haben meine damen und
herren von der union wir legen eine
grundlage oder bessere grundlagen für
die spitzenforschung die
begabtenförderung wird ausgebaut die
mittel für die
wissenschaftskommunikation es wurde
bereits erwähnt da kann man sich darüber
diskutieren dass wir diesen entwurf
besser machen wir sind ja am beginn der
haushaltsberatungen mal sehen was in
diesem jahr geht und was in den nächsten
jahren geht ich bin gespannt was wir
hier noch zusammen alles erreichen
können in dieser koalition
innovationen ermöglichen die
technologische souveränität
sicherstellen dass alles wird durch
diesen entwurf auf den weg gebracht wir
fördern neue konzepte die sprung
innovationsagentur eine
agentur die das wissen sie alle in den
letzten vier jahren vor allem von der
fdp eingefordert wurde wird jetzt
endlich so ausgestattet dass sie ihre
arbeit richtig machen kann die
zukunftstechnologien mikroelektronik
it-sicherheit die grundlagenforschung
auf europäischer ebene alles schon
angesprochen alles die grundlage die
unsere ministerin jetzt verantwortung
nach vorne bringen wird beste bildung
und forschung sind die grundlage unseres
wohlstandes die liegen das phänomen
fundament für eine zukünftige
prosperierende wirtschaft beste bildung
ist aber auch der war saale garant für
unsere intellektuelle souveränität die
grundlage für einen freien
selbstbestimmten selbstbewussten
menschen in einer liberalen gesellschaft
angelegt
angelehnt an den philosophen ludwig
wittgenstein damit schließlich könnte
man behaupten forschung und vor allem
lebenslange bildung ist ein kampf gegen
die verwechslung unseres verstandes und
das ist heute wichtiger denn je ich
freue mich auch die haushaltsberatungen
und danke ihnen für ihre aufmerksamkeit
vielen dank natürlich gemein
tja so schnell geht das mit dem
sexuellen wechseln also
wir sind voll im
zug der zeit das passiert
wolfgang kubicki auch wieder genesen hat
jetzt den vorsitz übernommen und thomas
jarzombek
von der tu sprecher für bildung und
forschung ist der nächste redner in
dieser debatte liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen erstmal muss ich sagen freue
ich mich dass ich überhaupt hier reden
darf als opposition nach den erfahrungen
im ausschuss scheint das keine
selbstverständlichkeit zu sein so
zweiter zweitens muss ich sagen respekt
für die redner für die redner der
koalition so viele modelle zum
schönreden sind uns in 16 jahren ist ein
gefallen
ich will einfach mal sagen mal ein paar
fakten auf dem tisch 100 tage bilanz von
ministerin ihre parlamentarische bilanz
ist zero sie reden über ganz vieles
angekommen ist hier nichts an vorlagen
punkt 2 das budget wir haben in 16
jahren diesen haushalt verdreifacht von
etwas über 7 milliarden auf zum schluss
fast 21 milliarden wir sind über all
diese jahre gestiegen sie sind die
ersten die ein fettes minus mitbringt es
sind - 650 millionen euro mit der
globalen minderausgabe - 650 millionen
euro das ist das erste mal seit 16
jahren dass dieser haushalt eine beule
kriegt und ich muss sagen als ich hörte
wir werden jetzt 100 milliarden für die
bundeswehr ausgegeben mit tollen
projekten julius wir wissen dass von der
darpa was da in anderen ländern geht wir
haben 100 milliarden für transformation
wir haben noch 60 milliarden
offensichtlich die mitgenommen werden
aus grüna und für den bildungshaushalt
ist nichts drin gar nichts ich muss
sagen das zeigt nicht dass dieses haus
gewicht in dieser regierung hat und das
ist für uns ein problem
das problem geht weiter und zwar ins bmw
k denn ein großer teil der
forschungsmittel sind da eine satte
milliarde zimmer verschwunden ist
einfach weg im oktober ist das
erfolgreiche programm ausgelaufen beim
druck der häuslebauer bei der kfw haben
sie nachgegeben die mittelständler
lassen sie verhungern im juni soll es
wieder starten das liege
anderthalbtausend unbearbeitete anträge
da bis das erste geld bewilligt wird ist
ein jahr um 600 millionen öffentliches
geld 400 milliarden millionen private
mittel weg
so ihre bilanz stand hölzl nach 100
tagen sind minus 1,65 milliarden wie
wollen sie denn das dreieinhalb prozent
ziel erreichen dass das völlig unklar
ihr staatssekretär thomas sattelberger
hatte im ausschuss gesagt auf meine
frage werden wir zum steinbruch bei
diesen ganzen neuen themen hat er gesagt
nein wir erreichen dass ich bin mal
gespannt wie er konnte ist ja leider
nicht einrichten heute hier zu sein
sonst könnte es uns möglicherweise
erklären zu ihrer bafög-reform sagt der
tagesspiegel heute stand heute
studentenwerk kritisiert minimal
korrektur studierende sehen reförmchen
das lasse ich einfach nur mal so im raum
stehen
parlaments reif haben sie gesagt sei
dieser entwurf wir also wir haben nix im
parlament ich habe letztens mit der gew
gesprochen und gefragt was haltet ihr
von dem entwurf das sagt die gew zu uns
wir sind gar nicht beteiligt worden in
verbänden verfahren was ist denn da los
also ich glaube beim handwerklichen beim
handwerklichen ist hilft das aufregen
leider nicht weiter sie könnte der gw
schicken firma zur da ziehe ich höre ja
seit 100 tagen von der partie ich habe
den kollegen sattelberger bei der
transfer konferenz gesehen hat sich das
selbst sehr gefallen und wurde geredet
von hunderten von millionen und so
weiter jetzt gucke ich in diesen entwurf
das stehen drin in worten 15 15
millionen euro
sie erlauben eine zwischenfrage
wie sie auch
ja lieber kollege jarzombek vielen dank
für ihre ausführungen zu ihren
erwartungen
wie schnell die ampel all die
wunderbaren projekte wie sie gesagt
haben jetzt auch umsetzt die haben sie
völlig zu recht und wir sind ja auch
schon dabei das sieht man daran dass
auch für die daten ja jetzt schon geld
eingestellt ist die natürlich noch zu
gründen ist dafür braucht es einen
anfangs budget bevor es dann natürlich
danach richtig loslegen kann ich will
mich nur erinnern an die gründung der
sprint die erst 2019 gegründet wurde
also deutlich mehr verzug im vergleich
zum koalitionsvertrag als das jetzt bei
der dati der fall ist die jetzt schon in
der gründungsphase quasi los geht und wo
schon in diesem jahr jetzt geld
eingestellt ist insofern wolle die zur
kenntnis nehmen dass wir da ziemlich
rasch unterwegs sind beim aufbau einer
solchen neuen innovationsagentur die
damit auch sehr schnell einen neuen
drive ins innovationssystem geben wird
in ein instrument das ja die union die
letzten jahre immer abgelehnt hat wo es
immer hieß da sei gar keine lücke die
man zu fühlen müsste also wollen sie zur
kenntnis nehmen dass er offensichtlich
doch eine lücke ist und dass wir die
sehr schnell jetzt ausfüllen werden
also liebe kollegin einer christmann ich
freue mich sehr für diesen punkt denn
wir gucken doch mal gemeinsam in das sie
nennt was der finanzminister
aufgeschrieben hat das ist ja die
beratungsgrundlage heute und da hat er
aufgeschrieben nicht nur 15 millionen
sondern er hat sie gesperrt bis zur
vorlage eines schlüssigen konzeptes und
das letzte mal dass der finanzminister
geschrieben hat gesperrt wegen nicht
vorhandener schlüssigen konzept das war
bei der pkw maut ich wünsche ihnen viel
erfolg auf dem weg diese partie ans
laufen zu bringen ich wünsche ihnen ich
wünsche ihnen ich wünsche
ja ich sag mal 100 tagen kann man auch
an schlüssiges konzept bauen ich halte
das durchaus für machbar
so uns
ja ja ja so und ich dachte ich darf doch
noch mal wenn wir bei der presse lektüre
sind und bei ihren kommentaren der
kollege kaczmarek hat gestern im
tagesspiegel soldati erklärt man müsse
jetzt erst einmal klären ob das konzept
eigentlich von der regierung oder von
den parlamentsfraktionen eingebracht
wird ich glaube wenn über die frage
heute noch gerne klarheit herrscht nach
100 tagen dann haben sie echt eine menge
strecke noch zu gehen und was diese
partie machen soll ich habe es nicht
verstanden ich sehe leute die sind
verliebt sie sind verliebt in einer
institution und jetzt wird er
zwangsläufig ein problem für gesucht und
das problem haben sie aber noch nicht
gefunden ich bin gespannt darauf
währenddessen und lieber einer
christmann sie verantworten ja im bmw k
solche themen lese ich auch im
tagesspiegel dass es bmw k das programm
für gf auf 200 millionen weitertreibt
und jetzt auch dabei ist das zu
modifizieren und genau die themen
anzugehen ja echt die partie angehen
soll vielleicht reden sie mal
miteinander wir haben nämlich gefragt
und da hat die ministerin im ausschuss
gesagt dass die staatssekretärin
brandner und der sattelberger viel
miteinander reden dann haben wir mal
gefragt wann war das eigentlich haben
wir keinen termin genannt bekommen dann
wurde uns noch gesagt über die milliarde
fonds im und über ex ist wurde nicht
geredet also ich frage mich was machen
sie eigentlich den ganzen 100 tagen und
ich habe heute die antworten der bild
-zeitung gefunden der kollege
sattelberger sie haben so leicht gesehen
er posiert im raumanzug auf tik tok r
streitet sich mit herrn kaeser auf
twitter
hat einen netten hund den er da
präsentiert und seine man hat ja auch
komplimente gemacht das finde ich
großartig
ich kann nur sagen ich kann am ende nur
sagen schluss mit den gags ran an den
speck so auf geht's
vielen dank
ein gag war dass wir dann vom redner
vielleicht von thomas jarzombek
ich habe jedenfalls diese zeichnung oder
diese bilder nicht erkannt sönke rix der
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
der spd für diesen bereich bildung und
forschung hat jetzt als nächster hier
[Applaus]
es ist nach niveau gerufen worden und
ich habe gesagt verweise erstmal
abwarten also das
bitte nicht den beiden ich vorher loben
aber ich will ganz kurz iba thomas hat
schon weg ganz kurz darauf eingehen sie
haben beschrieben oder du hast
beschrieben dass wir verliebtsein in die
jetzt irgendwie würde was wir daraus
machen ich sag besser als in dieses
projekt verliebtsein hat es in die
autobahnmaut oder die automat also das
muss man
durchaus sagen
und und besser besser verliebtsein in
solche sachen als in
raumfahrt taxis oder so also von daher
wollen wir waren wir gucken und ich
finde auch ganz normal mit verlaub die
hinweise auf auftritte auf tik tok von
von kollege sattelberger also das ist ja
kann man ja sehen wie man möchte aber
das entbehrt ja nicht dafür sie ja nicht
davon hier eigentlich auch mal ihre
ideen einzubringen hier mal zu sagen was
sie denn eigentlich machen wollen außer
die tatsache
außer die tatsache zu beschreiben dass
wir nicht schnell genug sind um all das
aufzuarbeiten was im cdu geführten
bildungsministerium so lange liegen
geblieben ist das ist ein bisschen wenig
finde ich für eine
für eine konstruktive opposition und das
habe ich ja eigentlich so verstanden
sollte es ja nicht sein ich habe mir
extra zettel und stift hingelegt und
gedacht na ja von thomas kammer
vielleicht noch ein bisschen was lernen
das war ein bisschen da habe ich das
habe ich leider vermisst aber vielleicht
bei der zweiten dritten lesung dann
gerne meine damen und herren muss man
auch diesen haushalt vor der aktuellen
lage betrachten die welt ist eine andere
seit wenigen tagen wenigen wochen gut
ins krieg gegen die ukraine hat die welt
dramatisch verändert
menschen verlieren leben fängt menschen
verlieren ihre zukunft ihrer heimat
menschen haben angst und jetzt ist es
ganz besonders wichtig auch gerade im
hinblick auf die situation in der
ukraine nicht nur den menschen in der
ukraine sondern insgesamt den menschen
zuversicht zu geben und sicherheit zu
vermitteln und das ist eine wesentliche
bestandteil dieser
da gibt es einmal die äußere sicherheit
darüber diskutieren wir im rahmen des
fahrrad haben wir diskutiert im rahmen
des verteidigungshaushaltes des
auswärtigen ausschusses
und sowieso um das ganze gesamte
programm nach der regierungserklärung
des bundeskanzlers gibt die innere
sicherheit wir haben alle ein bedürfnis
auch zu gucken was ist mit cyber
kriminalität anders geworden wie ist die
situation hat sich verändert es gibt die
sicherheitsfrage nach energie kann ich
mir die energie noch leisten kann ich
mehr gibt es eigentlich noch genügend
energie wird meine heizung eigentlich
immer noch funktionieren ich bin sowohl
der bundesregierung als auch der ampel
koalition insgesamt dass es auch diese
drei wesentlichen forderung und
angstsituationen auch antwort gegeben
hat wer wir sorgen dafür dass die
menschen sicherheit auch in diesen
feldern bekommen
und die menschen die hier aus der
ukraine zu uns flüchten wollen natürlich
auch hier eine sicherheit haben und da
bin ich dankbar all den menschen und
institutionen die dafür sorgen dass sich
richtig ankommen aber wir müssen den
menschen auch sagen wir kümmern uns auch
um eure sicherheit im rahmen von
ausbildung von bildung von betreuung von
schule auch das ist etwas wesentliches
und deshalb mit dem finanzminister
dankbar dass er sagt all das was wir da
an zusätzlichen ausgaben haben werden
wir auch noch mal so eine gesonderte im
etat auch nochmal ausweisen das ist
wichtiges signal glaube ich für die
geflüchteten menschen die zu uns kommen
und
wir brauchen die soziale sicherheit auch
für unsere für die menschen hier in
unserem land war gerade in zeiten von
umbruch da fragen sie sich ist denn all
das worauf ich mich noch bis vor wochen
monaten des vor kurzem auch noch
verlassen konnte ist das noch sicher und
deshalb brauchen wir die soziale
sicherheit und dazu gehört sicherheit
auch im bildungsbereich dazu gehört die
sicherheit zu sagen ja wir machen weiter
bei der digitalisierung von schulen ganz
im gegenteil wir machen nicht weniger
wir machen da sogar mehr in diesem
bereich und das ist die sicherheit die
die menschen brauchen wenn sie sagen
meine kinder sollen am ende auch mit
vernünftig ausgestattet seien im rahmen
der digitalisierung die die schule soll
digitalisiert sein das wollen wir
gemeinsam weiter mit den ländern machen
da gibt es keine abstriche diese
sicherheit geben wir
dann wollen wir das für studierende das
ist schon erwähnt worden war für
reformen natürlich ist es jetzt jeder
junge mensch fragt sich kann ich mir das
denn jetzt leisten wie sie hätten meine
soziale situation sein wie wird die
wirtschaftliche situation sein und wenn
wir dann als staat sagen ja wir schaffen
mit dem bafög auch eine absicherung für
dich wir sicherlich ab du kannst
studieren egal ob also eltern unabhängig
altersunabhängig und unkompliziert an
bafög ankommt das ist das was wir uns
vorgenommen haben das bietet sich
erhalten kollegen trainieren
und meine damen und herren was auch sehr
wichtig ist ist dass wir es insgesamt
auch schaffen für schülerinnen und
schülern an schulen die in besonderen
situationen zur schule geht an
besonderen orten der stadt chancen auch
verbessert da sagen wir als grund
gemeinsam mit den ländern wollen wir das
machen aber ich sage an dieser stelle
auch gemeinsam mit den männern und wir
wollen die länder nicht aus der
verantwortung lassen aber wir werden als
bund auch hier unseren beitrag leisten
und wir werden dafür sorgen dass all das
was wir im forschungsbereich im
wissenschaftsbereich auch angefangen
haben in der letzten koalition dass auch
das in krisenzeiten abgesichert ist und
wir wollen sogar noch mehr das ist
gerade im verband vorrednerin auch sehr
deutlich beschrieben also unterm strich
sicherheit im wandel ist wichtig und wir
leisten mit diesem vertrag serviert
diesem entwurf des haushalts ein erster
schritt dazu herzlichen danke
danke
[Applaus]
als nächste rednerin erhält das wort die
kollegin die kohle höchst hab die
fraktion
sind frau bundesministerin werte
kollegen meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren die erste haushaltsdebatte dient
einmal mehr dazu die bildungs lage oder
besser bildungs notlage der nation ganz
grundsätzlich zu betrachten frau stark
watzinger sie haben ein schweres erbe
angetreten sie übernahmen die
verantwortung für ein ideologisch
sturmreif geschossen das bildungssystem
in welche immer mehr schüler einser
abitur ablegen und gleichzeitig das
bildungsniveau immer weiter verfällt
schüler haben immer mehr kompetenzen
können aber immer weniger und das ist
traurige realität
trösten sie sich
trösten sie sich bei aller kritik ein
stück weit selbst ein wunder wäre
überfordert damit aus einer solch
erfahrenen ausgangslage ein bildungs
hochleistungs deutschland zu erschaffen
die jüngste kritik der generalkonsul in
der ukraine erteilte dem deutschen
schulsystem eine denkwürdige klatsche
sie bat darum die ukrainischen kinder
nach ukrainischen schulsystem zu
beschulen nach ukrainischen lehrplänen
mit ukrainischen lehrern ansonsten drohe
der ukraine eine verlorene generation
der unterricht in der ukraine sei
intensiver vollziehe sich in kürzerer
zeit als in deutschland und hätte ebenso
höhere anforderungen die kriegs
gebeutelte ukraine hält deutschland den
spiegel vor es gefällt nicht was wir
darin sehen nämlich die traurigen augen
einer verlorenen bildungs generation
deutschland
sie selbst sagt mir völlig zu das ist
nicht hinnehmbar sei dass ein fünftel
der schüler die schulen verlässt ohne
richtig lesen zu können doch wo sind
ihre lösung dabei wissen wir seit
jahrzehnten die schulinfrastruktur die
lehrer aus weiter und fortbildung
benötigen dringend eine große nationale
kraftanstrengung
leider frau ministerin setzt der
bildungshaushalt das lange warten auf
den großen wurf in der bildungspolitik
nahtlos fort bildung ist ganz
offensichtlich das ungeliebte stiefkind
der bunten republik deutschland
das drückt sich auch in nackten zahlen
nämlich dem rückgang des bildungsetats
um 2,5 prozent aus sie halten kurs ja
auf den eisberge vor der
flüchtlingskrise bis zur intellektuellen
kernschmelze kaputt reformiert weiterhin
überfrachtet mit unhaltbaren bunten
nachhaltigen und hauptsache ideologie
beseelten heilsversprechen sinkt das
bildungsniveau stetig weiter das bedingt
versäumte kann nicht nachgeholt werden
langen der digitalisierung babylonisches
sprachengewirr war in den klassen seelen
erschreckend viele kinder mit
todeswunsch und lehrermangel überall
liebe bild stand bildungsnotstand
leugner hier im saal und an der
regierung deutschland erwartet von ihnen
den blick auf die schulen dieses landes
nehmen sie ihre kollegen von der ampel
in strenge gebet und holen sie alle
fraktionen in bund und ländern ins boot
für diesen überfälligen neustart es muss
ihnen doch klar sein die zukunft unseres
landes wird an den schulen entschieden
ohne studieren
ohne studiert und ausbildungsreife
schulabsolventen wird es keinen
nachwuchs für hochschulen und betriebe
für wissenschaft forschung und damit
kein wohlstand und lebensglück für
möglichst alle mehr geben wir müssen
endlich zurück in die zukunft heißt
rückkehr zu den kernaufgaben von schule
und bildung rechnen schreiben
kreatives vernetzen kritisches denken
meine damen und herren in deutschland
das früher einmal die meisten
nobelpreisträger hervorbrachte dessen
dreigliedriges schulsystem und
berufliche bildung weltweit führend
meine damen und herren und wir werden
hier noch einmal raus gehen aus dieser
debatte weil der amerikanische präsident
joe biden sich erneut in brüssel vor dem
eu äußert
liebe unser höchstes gut unsere ganze
hoffnung für unsere gesellschaftliche
zukunft ihre gesundheit in schutz und
ihre bildung haben allerhöchste
priorität
ihre geistige und moralische
unabhängigkeit ist die essenz unserer
freiheit und demokratie und das möchten
die in ihrem haushalt ganz grundsätzlich
abgebildet sehen vielen dank
in höchst
[Applaus]
nächste reden lässt der kollege kai
gehring bündnis 90 minuten
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen heute können wir mit freude
endlich den ersten haushalt für bildung
und forschung beraten der mehr
chancengerechtigkeit
innovationsfreude und zukunfts mut atmet
was wir heute klug investieren herzig
morgen doppelt und dreifach aus wir
leben in einer zeit wo ziegler krisen
krieg
klimakatastrophe pandemie krise
wissenschaft und forschung sind
frühwarnsystem und helfen uns diese und
andere krisen zu bewältigen würden alle
gleichermaßen auf wissenschaft hören
dann wäre für krisen vorsorgen so viel
gewonnen
missionswerks wirklich vorstellen
vorschlag für klima- energie- frieden
migration und gesundheit sind kein nice
to have sondern elementar für die
resilienz und robustheit unserer
gesellschaft
bildung und forschung sind die quellen
unseres künftigen wohlstands wachstums
und fortschritt und daumen muss gerade
jetzt besser finanziert werden wenn wir
die 2020er jahre zum jahrzehnte
zukunftsinvestitionen machen wollen ja
soweit also der amerikanische präsident
joe biden in brüssel hier mit einem
neuen statement morgen reist er dann
weiter nach warschau und wird dort
weitere gespräche führen
das ist natürlich auch ein symbol und
anzeichen dass der amerikanische
präsident
die polnische hauptstadt besucht die ja
quasi die polen die hauptlast tragen
moment zumindest was die
flüchtlingsaufnahme geht so wir sind
jetzt wieder zurück hier im deutschen
bundestag bei der debatte um den
bildungsetat jährigen er ist der
vorsitzende im ausschuss für bildung
forschung und technikfolgenabschätzung
von den grünen er hat seine rede vor
kurzem begonnen
für 2025 werden es über vier milliarden
euro mehr werden für schulen hochschulen
azubis studios für labore und forschende
unternehmen
zentrale projekte gleisen wir
2022 auf mit dem startchancen programm
für bildungsgerechtigkeit werden wir
schulen in benachteiligten regionen und
quartieren unterstützen der digital park
bekommt ein update um unsere schulen
endlich fit zu machen für lehren und
lernen im digitalen zeitalter und die
überfällige modernisierung des bafögs
läuft jetzt an und bewerteten mehr
angetreten beim chancengerechtigkeit
gesetz entwickeln
jetzt höre ich von den oppositionsbänken
das reicht alles noch nicht ist ja klar
den 100 tagen kann ich alles anders aber
vieles besser werden ich wünsche mir
lassen sie uns wettstreiten um die
besten konzepte 100 tage ohne
oppositionsanträge da fehlt uns was
lassen sie uns gern zusammenwirken damit
deutschland ein agileres land der ideen
wird mit chancen für alle egal welcher
herkunft von kita bis weiterbildung mit
offenheit für neues mit strategien zur
fachkräftesicherung und besseren
arbeitsbedingungen in der wissenschaft
und mehr dynamik im innovationsprozess
und gerade als ausschussvorsitzender bin
ich optimistisch dass wir als
selbstbewusstes parlament auch diesen
haushalt an notwendigen stellen noch
besser machen werden
wichtig
den absagen der ergänzungs haushalt mit
dem wir auf den russischen angriffskrieg
reagieren denn hunderttausende schüler
innen studierende und forschende
ukrainische sowie aus drittstaaten
müssen vor krieg fliehen ihre aufnahme
ist eine mammutaufgabe für unser
bildungs und forschungssystem
wissenschaftsfreiheit und weltweit werte
geleitete wissenschaftskooperation
zeichnen uns als land aus daher ist das
einfrieren institutioneller kooperation
mit dem putin regime so wichtig und wir
können auch viele programme und der
erfahrung aus 2015 folgende
zurückgreifen die verfolgten programme
aufstocken welcome und integral sind
blaupausen für jetzt und die
hilfsbereitschaft hier im land ist
derzeit riesengroß an schulen in
ausbildungsbetrieben und an hochschulen
von hk über cth bis der ade danke an
allen die sich engagieren
[Applaus]
ich wünsche mir in einer zeit uns der
krieg auf der seele liegt und corona
noch in den knochen steckt eine neue
kultur der zusammenarbeit vor allem
zwischen grund ländern und kommunen im
sinne eines kooperativen
bildungsföderalismus
und einer verantwortungsgemeinschaft für
bessere bildung sei es bei der aufnahme
von geflüchteten der bewältigung der
korona folgen die überfällige
modernisierung unserer
bildungseinrichtung und die
technologische souveränität europas oder
die klimagerechte transformation die
herausforderung sind riesig und sind in
den letzten jahren angewachsen sie
dulden keinen aufschub und mit diesem
haushalt ist ein wichtiger schritt getan
ich freue mich auf die beratung für mehr
zukunfts mut und mehr
zukunftsinvestition
kai gehring seit dieser
legislaturperiode
der neue ausschussvorsitzende für
bildung forschung und technologie volk
technologie folgenabschätzung heißt es
bedarf und er hat noch gesagt dass
natürlich die aufgaben die jetzt auch in
folge des krieges auf deutschland
zukommt gerade im bereich der aufnahme
der flüchtlinge wird es nötig sein dass
auch dieser bereich im ergänzungs
haushalt bedacht hat petra sitte jetzt
für die linke
ich habe mich also zu ihrem haushalt zu
äußern der in einer koalition unter
einem koalitionsvertrag geschrieben
worden ist der mit dem label läuft mehr
fortschritt wagen das ist ja erst mal
eine tolle geschichte und löst bei mir
meine erwartungen aus fortschritt
beginnt mit bildung und forschung wir
durften also von ihnen fulminantes
erwarten bei der überschrift was aber es
passiert nur chancen ministerium so wie
sie es vorhin bezeichnet haben hat erst
erstes mal die chance genutzt um 25
prozent gekürzt zu werden da passt was
nicht zusammen ich kann es ihnen nicht
ersparen werden 100 milliarden euro für
die bundeswehr als investitionen in
freiheit und zukunft bezeichnet muss
sich hier fragen lassen wieso werden
ausgaben von bildung und forschung nicht
genauso bewertet sie wollten sie wollten
doch hier das aufstiegsversprechen und
mehr bildungsgerechtigkeit umsetzen ihre
mission muss doch sein gemeinsam mit den
ländern in den nächsten vier jahren
dafür zu sorgen dass das bildungs- und
hochschulsystem endlich aus finanziert
wird sie haben gute ideen in ihrem
koalitionsvertrag ich nenne mal nur die
gleichstellung oder die das begegnen von
hochschulen für angewandte forschung und
angewandte wissenschaften und
universitäten auf augenhöhe dann bis
werden sie aber nicht zum nulltarif
bekommen schon gar nicht für weniger sie
brauchen für die fachhochschulen zugang
zu förderprogrammen
sie brauchen die angleichung von der
leistungen sie brauchen andere
besoldungs strukturen sie brauchen mehr
anreize für die entwicklung eines
wissenschaftlichen mittelbaus oder eben
dann auch die unterstützung von ihrer
seite für die länder für die hochschulen
bei der einrichtung von promotionsrecht
'nen an diesen hochschulen für
angewandte forschung und nun fragt man
sich doch wie soll das alles gehen sie
müssen mit den ländern finanzieren und
da können wir hier fünfmal über die
daten sprechen sie wird das problem
nicht lösen insofern
will ich nur sagen auch wenn sie einen
zusatz haushalt machen für insbesondere
jene die aus der ukraine kommen für die
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern für neustart
drinnen und schüler wenn sie das erst in
dem zusatz haushalt in dem
einstellen dann hoffe ich nur dass wir
nicht die gleiche überraschung erleben
wie mit diesem haushalt
vielen dank brauche sind dies auch die
methode die machten auf den letzten
meter zu verlängern ist also
aber dann versteht man sie auch nicht
mehr ganz so gut also kita sieht man
dass der nächste redner ist mario brandt
sprecher für forschung technologie und
innovation der fdp
willkommen zurück herr präsident
liebe frau ministerin die wir kollegen
legen gerne hätte ich rede zum haushalt
gehalten aber leider hat sich mein
zettel hier aufgrund der vielen thesen
gefüllt und ich möchte sagen es war
schön ja ja sag doch mal darauf eingehen
da die und der vorwurf dass die gelder
gesperrt sind es ist ordentliche
buchführung dass wenn ein konzept noch
nicht da liegt die gelder gesperrt
werden und da ist es egal ob das
hausgeld ist und das andere haus grün
das nennt sich compliance das ist aber
nicht immer ihre stärke ist kann man
beispielsweise an dabei der xl forschung
im vorgarten gerne einmal die
bildungsministerin und
dann wird kritisiert dass es nur um 15
millionen geht für etwas was in gründung
ist wir sprechen hier über dieses jahr
da geht es darum leute einzustellen im
gebäude von mir das noch irgendwie in
kicker ein kaffeeautomat und das ding
einfach mal auf die straße zu setzen und
das zu kritisieren zeigt aber den
elementaren unterschied wir überlegen
uns projekte schauen was die kosten und
schreiben sie in den haushalt sie
schreiben einfach geld in den haushalt
und hoffen dass irgendjemand werk daraus
macht und deswegen sind abgewählt
deswegen machen wir es
immer drei die spring ich habe mir das
sitzen stunden anhören müssen jetzt
müssen sich am stück anhören wir haben
noch viel spaß im ausschuss ne ne ne ne
das tut weh 60 minuten ich habe nur noch
130 wir machen das jetzt fertig dann
kommt was zu der springt das fand ich an
der stelle wirklich interessant denn das
ist doch eigentlich auch ihr baby wir
versuchen doch gerade hier ihren baby
mehr freiheit zu geben weil wir uns im
ziel doch eigentlich einig sind wo wir
hin wollen eben mehr diskutiere
innovationen aus deutschland
und wenn wir dann versuchen quasi ihr
baby zu befreien was sie gefesselt haben
und sie uns dann an feinden dann werde
ich an der stelle ehrlich gesagt leider
nicht gut aus aber vielleicht können sie
mir dann im ausschuss erklären wo sie
dann mit hinwollten
und dann weil sie sich jetzt persönlich
angegriffen fühlen muss ich dem kollegen
sattelberger zur seite springen wenn
jemand in quarantäne ist dann ist
endlich im plenum ich glaube dass es in
der cdu/csu-fraktion ähnlich ich würds
jeden fall hoffen das ist der gängige
rahmen und insofern war der antwort
billig wenn es nicht gewusst haben dann
ist ein schwamm drüber
leider waren so viele angriffe das noch
nicht mal drei minuten reichen denn ich
fand auch putzig hier das tik tok
verhalten von herrn sattelberger zu
kritisieren und dann den satz zu sagen
mit erfand sich in seiner rolle auf
gegen einen wegen dem podium oder
sonstigen gut als er seinen weg wenn sie
dritter hand gehabt hätten hätten sich
noch gefilmt beim reden deswegen sollten
auch seine eigenen ausgegeben
leider ist jetzt kein zweifel bewegen
was inhaltlich ist freue mich auf den
ausschuss wünschen einen schönen abend
daher wäre es
schön wenn hier gegen halb acht noch
gelacht werden kann im hohen hause das
ist der dritte tag der
haushaltsberatungen der einzelplan 30
bildung und forschung wird hier heute
beraten 20,3 milliarden euro fließen in
das ressort von jetzt wieder starten
trotzdem das sind 25 prozent weniger als
im vorjahr und die nicht reden will
kommt von der cdu/csu in dieburg recht
[Applaus]
wirklich und eigentlich auch unsere
mission unwürdig ich möchte frau
ministerin schon noch mal darauf
zurückkommen dass wir einen extrem
dynamischen den haushalt bis jetzt
hatten im forschungsbereich den
dynamischsten überhaupt in der
bundesregierung und jetzt starten sie
mit einem minus von 25 wir finden das
ausgesprochen bedauerlich wenn man sich
die kürzung anschaut dann sieht man dass
in der allgemeinen projektförderung um
acht prozent gekürzt wurde das ist da wo
kreativität und flexibilität sitzt das
ist da übrigens wo das forschungsschiff
polarstern aufgebrochen ist so einer
wirklich beeindruckenden reise 8 prozent
weniger das ist eine empfindliche
kürzung wenn man sich jetzt anschaut wo
der bereich des größten wachstums ist
dann ja wohl ministerium +16 fürs
personal das ist doch unangemessen und
auch das lässt schon viele fragen
wirklich viele fragen offen deswegen wir
sehen nicht dass hier außer dem
weihrauchfass dass hier wirklich
prioritäten gesetzt wurden und das
zukunfts erwartungen erfüllt werden
schade schade
2009 10 gab es eine bafög erhöhung von
15 prozent jetzt gibt es 240 millionen
euro mehr aber natürlich nur für die
korona folgen ich finde es wichtig den
studentinnen studenten die korona folgen
abzufedern ich selbst weiß wie wichtig
bafög ist ich habe sowohl das abitur
gemacht als auch zu studieren angefangen
mit dem bafög nur glaube ich dass man
auch hier wirklich kleine brötchen
backen müssen wir aufhören muss
selbstverständlichkeiten mit einer lobo
delight übergießen die schwer erträglich
ist alle normal denkenden menschen
ich möchte
unsere aufmerksamkeit wenden wenn denn
auf das aufstiegs bafög die
gleichbehandlung der ausbildungsgänge
muss uns wichtig sein beruflicher
ausbildung akademische ausbildung gerade
wenn wir sehen wie wichtig der die
berufliche schiene in den kommenden
jahren sein wird ich war gestern beim
baden-württembergischen
handwerkskammertag er in berlin
hier zu gast war und die kollegen dort
sagten uns dass sie für die energiewende
für die wärmepumpen den bedarf an wärme
kommen und dass sie dafür
60.000 zusätzliche monteure auch in
60.000 das heißt hier müssen wir doch
geld zur verfügung stellen damit die
meister auch ausbilden können wir müssen
hier viel mehr tun als bis jetzt werden
wir es schaffen und das ist keine kritik
ritter kritisieren sondern das ist eine
fundamentale aufgabe der des
klimawandels das management des
klimawandels also statt freitags for
future montag bis freitag fürs klima
noch ein punkt wasserstoff für den
ausbau müssen alle ebenen zusammenwirken
mit vereinfachung von planungs und
genehmigungsverfahren meine
oberbürgermeister aus schwäbisch gmünd
hat mir vor zehn tagen diese 176 seiten
in die hand gedrückt das ist ein
leitfaden für die für eine für die
genehmigung einer wasserstofftankstelle
eine wir brauchen eine
und jetzt schlägt das ich mit der
industrie emissionsrichtlinien der eu
herum die in deutschland so umgesetzt
wurde das egal welche menge produziert
wird für die herstellung das ganze
komplexe verfahren durchlaufen werden
muss in frankreich geht es nur ab 40
kilo pro tag ja wir reden ja doch auch
immer über bessere planung so fahren wir
müssen doch auch darüber reden was für
jenseits des geldes noch machen müssen
unsere vorschlag wäre machen sie sich
daran die ganzen technologie skeptiker
sitzen jetzt bei ihnen der regierung
packen sie's an weil wir ein ich wollen
dass die energiewende gelingt machen sie
was deutschland wartet geld ist nicht
alles
strukturreform sind wichtig schreibt die
expertenkommission forschung und
innovation in einem übrigens
beeindruckenden gutachten und auch der
bundesrechnungshof schreibt es wir
müssen auch in den nächsten den nächsten
monaten über diese lange
leidensgeschichte der bund länder
beziehung reden jede regierung hat die
bisher alten sie führen frau ministerin
ein ministerium des goldenen zügel der
bund kaufte sich mit sprache über
zuschüsse
51 prozent der mittel entfallen auf bund
länder vereinbarung der bund zahlt die
länder schaffen an oder auch nicht und
der bund hat nur wenig folgen mit wenig
möglichkeiten der mitwirkung das gilt
übrigens auch für den nachfolger des
hochschulpakts und die freecom sind
bildungsplattform ich glaube dass wir
gut daran täten
die die strukturen zu vereinfachen dass
wir gut daran täten mit mut die dinge so
zu vereinfachen dass auch die
projektträger vor ort und die kommunen
besser mit dem zusammenkommen was an
regulierung vorgelegt wird und übrigens
fehlt dann auch nicht mehr dass geld die
neue aufgabe das ist der stoff aus dem
veränderung gemacht werden und da haben
haben sie uns an ihrer seite dankeschön
[Applaus]
15 sekunden
ich habe mich bedankt
nächste rednerin ist die kollegen dr
caroline wagner spd fraktion es ist ihre
erste parlaments mit
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte frau ministerin wehrte damen und
herren bildung digitalisierung um
nachhaltigkeit sind drei eckpfeiler auf
die gesetzen müssen um deutschland fit
für die zukunft zu machen genau deshalb
sind diese drei bereiche als
schwerpunkte im koalitionsvertrag
enthalten genau deshalb finden sich
diese drei bereiche im titel des
jahresgutachten der wirtschaftsweisen
mit blick auf den bildungsetat greifen
diese drei bereiche genau deshalb
unmittelbar zusammen da geht es
natürlich um bildung klar sonst wäre es
nicht der bildungsetat aber es geht auch
zentral um digitalisierung die auch den
bildungsbereich massiv verändert und
deshalb nehmen wir eben viel geld in die
hand um etwa mit dem digital parkschule
digitale kompetenzen schon im
kindesalter zu verankern und so zu
recht natürlich meine damen und herren
denn wir müssen eine digital kompetente
eine medienkritische gesellschaft werden
denn auch das ist ein zentraler pfeiler
für ein resident das land das wir neben
der debatte um militärische ausrüstung
für unsere der haft ich kite nicht aus
den augen verlieren dürfen
wird aber nur dann zu guter bildung wenn
sie nachhaltig ist wenn sie auf
professionellen auf didaktischen
konzepten basiert dafür braucht es in
allen bildungsbereichen das am besten
ausgebildete fachpersonal und für dieses
braucht es dass die besten
arbeitsbedingungen
unsere andere koalition zeigt sich
hierfür als verlässlicher partner und
leistet mit einem großen posten für das
bund länder programm zur förderung des
wissenschaftlichen nachwuchses einen
beitrag hierzu dass werte damen und ist
sicherheit im wandel
mit über 20 milliarden euro fördern wir
effektiv und darauf kommt es an effektiv
die ressource in diesem land ganz viele
kluge köpfe und mit unseren maßnahmen
wie etwa dem startchancen programm oder
den lebenschancen bafög werden wir
strukturen im bildungssystem spürbar
verbessern wir heben potenziale und
erneuern damit unser versprechen des
bildungsausschusses
beim bafög etwa hören wir endlich auf
mit pflaster und tupfer das system am
laufen zu halten nein wir unterziehen
ist jetzt der überlebensnotwendigen
operation denn nach jahren sinkender
geförderten quote wollen wir endlich
wieder deutlich mehr junge talente aus
einkommensschwachen familien fördern
damit sie ein studium aufnehmen damit
eben eine akademische ausbildung nicht
länger vom geldbeutel der eltern abhängt
wird die kolleginnen und kollegen
und all diese dinge darf eine sache
niemals zu kurz kommen und das ist das
thema gleichstellung gerade einmal 26
prozent der professuren in diesem land
sind von frauen besetzt zu viele
weibliche talente gehen und zum
wissenschaftssystem verloren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen und deshalb
deshalb ist es richtig dass wirkung von
den maßnahmen wie etwa das
professorinnenprogramm weiterhin
finanziert werden denn es führt bei den
beteiligten hochschulen zu einem enormen
wandel auch und gerade für die darunter
liegenden qualifikationsstufen meine
sehr geehrten damen und herren bildung
ist der schlüssel zur welt gute bildung
führt eher zu einem sicheren
arbeitsplatz und einem höheren einkommen
eher zur bessere gesundheitsversorgung
und teilhabe bildung ist das fundament
für ein selbstbestimmtes leben im sinne
der sozialdemokratie und dafür sorgen
wir in der zukunft koalition der ampel
unter anderem eben mit unseren
bildungsvorhaben chancengerechtigkeit
und aufstiegschancen fallen nicht
einfach so vom himmel man muss sie aktiv
durch strukturen herstellen und
verankern und darum kümmern wir uns hier
schaffen perspektiven
wir schaffen zukunft für 83 millionen
menschen vielen herzlichen dank
sagen ja hier mit ihrer ersten rede die
39-jährige ist zweifache mutter und ist
über die landesliste bayern er in den
deutschen bundestag eingezogen
michael kaufmann im ausschuss für
bildung forschung und technologie
folgenabschätzung für die afg hat jetzt
das wort hier im plenum
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte kollegen abgeordnete
der koalitionsvertrag der ampel ist im
hinblick auf das thema forschung vor
allem eine sammlung von phrasen und
luftigen absichtsbekundungen ich habe
mir vor dem haushaltsentwurf klarheit
darüber erhofft wie denn die koalition
ihrem motto mehr fortschritt wagen in
die tat umsetzen möchte bei diesem motto
sollte doch wohl eine substanzielle
kraftanstrengung im bereich der
forschung zu erwarten sein die sich auch
monetär widerspiegelt
stattdessen
sinkt der altar des bundesministeriums
für bildung und forschung im gegensatz
zur bundesministerin kann ich keine
steigerung erkennen
doch es gibt lichtblicke
in einigen bereichen
wird deutlich in forschung investiert so
zum beispiel im bereich der photonik
zu den deutlich höheren ausgaben für it
sicherheit kann ich nur sagen guten
morgen endlich aufgewacht
doch den lichtblicken im haushalt stehen
enttäuschungen und fragezeichen
gegenüber im koalitionsvertrag findet
sich unter anderem der satz ich zitiere
unsere hochschulen für angewandte
wissenschaften werden wir als herz des
wissenschaftssystems stärken
warum liebe ampel wird dann der etat für
forschung und an fachhochschulen gekürzt
versprochen gebrochen
ein weiteres großes fragezeichen steht
hinter den posten
nachhaltigkeit klima energie diesen
titel wollen sie ernsthaft im aktuellen
bundeshaushalt kürzen
ich vermute dass hinter dieser kürzung
nicht die einsicht steht diese mittel
zukunftsträchtiger einsetzen zu wollen
vielmehr befürchte ich dass der
finanzminister intransparente fonds
plant um diesen posten am haushalt
vorbei finanzieren zu können
thema energie bei der gegenwärtigen lage
sollte doch klar sein dass erhebliche
anstrengungen auch in der forschung
nötig sind um eine sichere bezahlbare
energieversorgung in unserem land zu
gewährleisten
hierzu vermisse ich im aktuellen
haushaltsentwurf den passenden
schwerpunkt rund um deutschland werden
neue kernkraftwerke geplant und gebaut
in polen in tschechien in holland und in
frankreich sowieso warum sind wir als
führende forschungsstandort auf
kernenergie aus unseren nachbarländern
angewiesen
selbst
selbst die eu-kommission drückt der
kernkraft einem grünen stempel auf die
deutsche industrie dort den anschluss
nicht verpassen und soll nein muss sich
am ausbau der kernkraft in unseren
nachbarländern und weltweit beteiligen
und natürlich brauchen wir
kerntechnische forschung an unseren
universitäten und forschungszentren
dieses thema
dieses thema fehlt völlig im titel
innovation durch neue technologien die
ampel steht hier auf rot
ich freue mich auf eine konstruktive
diskussion des haushaltsentwurfs vielen
dank
michael kaufmann war dass von der af die
mit dem einzelplan 30 bildung und
forschung geht der dritte tag dieser
haushaltsberatung hier im deutschen
bundestag zu ende morgen früh meldet
sich meine kollegin jeanette klag um 8
uhr 45 wieder da geht es als erstes um
den haushalt arbeit und soziales und
gegen mittag dann wird der
gesamthaushalt noch mal beraten und
abgestimmt bei uns geht jetzt weiter in
bonn mit thomas
schönberger bündnis 90/die grünen und
hier kann ich sagen weil angemeldet mit
ihrer ersten parlaments
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte frau ministerin
liebe kolleginnen der demokratischen
fraktionen politik war in meinem leben
immer wichtig es war das thema am
esstisch und das nicht nur weil mein opa
gemeinderat war dass das nicht bei allen
menschen so ist weiß ich aber es ist
unsere politische verantwortung unsere
demokratie für alle menschen erlebbar zu
machen
in bildungseinrichtungen ist vieles
hinten runtergefallen während der
pandemie kulturelle angebote für ihre
schulprojekte besucher von synagogen die
politische bildung ist zu kurz gekommen
gleichzeitig haben sich mit corona
antisemitische verschwörungstheorien in
allen teilen unserer gesellschaft
verbreitet das ist eine gefahr für
unsere demokratie
aus meiner forschungsarbeit an der uni
münchen weiß ich wer glaubt das mächtige
eliten im hintergrund strippen ziehen
hält demokratie und politische teilhabe
für verachtenswerte und nutzloses
theater die folge sind antisemitische
gewalttaten auch mandatsträger innen
werden zur zielscheibe gemeinderäte
genauso wie wir bundestagsabgeordnete
bei der stärkung unserer demokratie
leisten geistes und sozialwissenschaften
einen unerlässlichen beitrag etwa die
antisemitismusforschung und ich finde
das muss mehr anerkennung finden auch in
diesem haushalt
wenn wir die symptome einer verfehlten
bildungspolitik nicht nur abmildern
wollen wenn wir unsere offene
demokratische gesellschaft und ihre
menschen stärken wollen dann brauchen
wir eine zukunftsfähige politische
bildung die nicht mithalten lösungen auf
neue herausforderungen reagiert und das
gibt es mit uns
wir müssen pädagoginnen das
handwerkszeug mitgeben für den umgang
mit jeglicher diskriminierung
verschwörungs ideologien und fade muss
auch dafür brauchen wir die über 70
millionen euro die für eine
qualitätsoffensive in der ausbildung von
lehrkräften vorgesetzt sind
genauso müssen wir die medienkompetenz
stärken die fähigkeit zu filtern und
quellen auf ihre seriosität zu
überprüfen das ist unverzichtbar zur
heutigen kommunikationsgesellschaft es
muss
es muss unser anspruch sein dass jeder
mensch der unser bildungssystem
durchlaufen hat gegen verschwörungs
ideologien und antisemitische
einstellungen gewappnet ist
und das ist da defizite gibt sieht man
auch hier im wohnhaus genau
genau deshalb brauchen wir mehr und
bessere politische bildung durch
programme wie bildung für nachhaltige
entwicklung gemeinsam mit entschied aus
in kooperation mit initiativen und
stiftungen mit den ländern über
ministerien und fachbereiche hinweg von
der kita bis hin zur erwachsenenbildung
bringen mit den stein ins rollen
liebe kolleginnen eine demokratie kann
nur funktionieren wenn die menschen auch
dahinter stehen mit zukunftsfähiger
moderner politische bildung machen wir
unsere demokratie stark robust und
wehrhaft wir legen die grundlage für die
gesellschaft der vielen
menschen für demokratie für unsere
offene gesellschaft zu begeistern das
muss im fokus stehen auch im
bildungssystem vielen dank
[Applaus]
nächste rednerin ist die kollegin
martina engel hat kopf cdu die situation
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte frau ministerin
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
in diesen tagen wir uns deutlich vor
augen geführt wie wichtig ressourcen und
rohstoffe für unser land sind sie bilden
die basis für jegliche wertschöpfung
alle branchen und bereiche leben
engpässe knappheit preissteigerungen in
einem ausmaß wie es vorher nicht denkbar
gewesen wäre über die wohl wichtigste
ressource die wir in unserem land haben
reden wir heute es ist das humankapital
es sind die kompetenzen fähigkeiten und
fertigkeiten sie die menschen in unserem
land haben und
diese wertvolle ressource weiter
auszubauen zu stärken zu entwickeln
braucht es weiter beste
rahmenbedingungen beste bildungschancen
im bereich duale ausbildung hochschule
aber auch lebensbegleitendes lernen fort
und weiterbildungsangebote ich möchte
heute meiner rede den schwerpunkt auf
die berufliche bildung legen die häufig
zu kurz kommt unser duales
ausbildungssystem ist der markenkern der
deutschen berufsausbildung viele länder
beneiden uns und gut ausgebildete
fachkräfte
auszubildende die zeitgleich in betrieb
und den schulen auf einem sehr hohen
niveau
praxisorientiert ausgebildet werden
an beruflichen schulen werden techniker
und meister ausgebildet die in
verantwortungsvollen bereichen gerade im
handwerk eine hervorragende arbeit
leisten und damit dass in der zukunft
auch so bleibt braucht es auch eine
transformation der beruflichen bildung
veränderungsprozesse machen vor der
arbeitswelt nicht halt digitalisierung
automatisierung diktator eine zunehmende
vernetzung halten einzug ins
arbeitsleben was kann der bund tun wir
brauchen weiter bundeseinheitliche
standards und anpassungen im bereich der
ausbildungsordnungen rahmenlehrpläne
neue berufsbilder müssen zügig erkannt
werden im zuge der transformation der
wirtschaft der industrie entsprechend
auch aufgesetzt und umgesetzt werden wir
müssen hier schnell reagieren dann wird
wir auch gut qualifizierte fachkräfte
für morgen ausbilden die insbesondere
auch im bereich der it aber im handwerk
im bereich der pflege hier entsprechend
auch auf der höhe der zeit gut
ausgebildet und qualifiziert werden
die letzte bundesregierung hat in diesem
bereich einiges auf den weg gebracht ich
denke an die reform im bereich der
pflege letzten freitag hatten wir von
der union einen entsprechenden antrag
auch zur weiterbildung zur
entsprechenden umstellung im bereich
medizinische fachangestellte wir
brauchen hier berufsbilder auf der höhe
der zeit um entsprechend für die zukunft
versorgung zu gewährleisten aber auch um
wettbewerbsfähig zu bleiben mit anderen
ländern unsere wirtschaft die bereiche
die pflege der gesundheitsbereich alle
branchen nur so können wir auch bestehen
wir brauchen beste ausgebildete
fachkräfte aber auch die entsprechenden
lernorte darf ich denke und die
beruflichen schulen heute angesprochen
wurde bereits der digital packt an
schulen und ich kann ihnen sagen aus der
praxis kommen es scheitert unser
bürokratie wir haben umfangreiche
förderrichtlinien sie nicht umgesetzt
werden können vor ort und das führt dann
auch zu den vollen fördertöpfen und
entsprechend vor ort zu schwierigen
umsetzungen und ich bitte hier dringend
auch den prozess zu verschlanken zu
vereinfachen wir brauchen einen booster
für innovationsstarke innovative
lernorte damit wir entsprechend hier vor
ort auch eine gute arbeit machen können
es gibt viele steine die wir noch
ansprechen könnten ich komme aber zum
abschluss transformationen der
beruflichen bildung der bund muss auch
taktgeber sein mit den ländern gemeinsam
so können wir entsprechen weiter kräftig
investieren und die berufliche bildung
in eine zukunft führen vielen herzlichen
dank für
den polittalk